[Music]
quick question how are you creating
value for your company with your data
this might sound like a broad question
but give us a minute to explain before
answering imagine you have an excellent
IT strategy and the proper
infrastructure in place with AI and HPC
adding GPUs to your HPC is where the
magic happens by operating in a cloud
environment
GPUs work in conjunction with the server
CPU to accelerate application and
processing performance meet every
workload demand with bare metal and
virtual server monthly and hourly
options solve complex problems faster
and with less power consumed than with
traditional CPUs choose the GPU that
best meets your needs and pay only when
you need it seamlessly integrate into
the IBM cloud infrastructure API and
management tools
no matter your industry accelerated
computing is becoming a necessity to
create critical business insights and
gain the competitive edge whether it be
a healthcare company training a chatbot
to provide better customer service a
petroleum company using reservoir
simulation to reduce the environmental
risk and enormous cost of exploration
for new oil fields or teaching
autonomous cars to adhere the rules of
the road these data intensive workloads
require fast secure and cost-effective
cloud infrastructure customers have said
that their GPU gives them the
flexibility to pay hourly or monthly and
shrink a 10 day process to mere hours by
running NVIDIA GPUs on IBM cloud you
could take their word for it or
experience GPUs for yourself so how will
you create value for your company with
your data